alors il ya un truc qui me fascine c'est
qu'ils ont trouvé un truc en fait qui
remet en cause toutes vos théories mon
cher ami tu as aussi sur celui là c'est
l'inventeur de lussi in the sky
découvez de longue date là oui bien sûr
ce serait un petit mec comme ça à côté
de belle isle adam alan bollard alors il
faut vous dire que dans les îles les
animaux en général diminuent de talent
vous voyez diminuer ses rêves dans les
îles un métier année dans les teams de
l'indonésie dans les îles des antilles
cd quantité de petits bestiaux et qui
ont ils sont devenus vraiment petit mais
les éléphants qui était sûrement sur le
continent asiatique sont devenus quatre
fois plus petit dans cet hymne de flores
ya un crocodile qui est aussi tout petit
et le bonhomme finalement a subi le même
la même pression de l'environnement ça
du met d'ailleurs un certain temps et il
est devenu en effet tout petit il a eu
un boom de leur remettre un maître pour
avoir ces coiffes ici adapté pour avoir
pour mieux jouer mais laisse moi serait
naturel c'est étonnant fermes allemandes
et les vestiaires on le savait on le
sait à travers tout penser à ses abonnés
fois qu'on a la preuve qu' un homme au
récit un peu subir comme comme des sons
comme les autres devenues pic mais
je vous jure ça me fascine amont sur la
terre j'écoute il ya eu des néandertal
oui on vécu en même temps que des
cro-magnons oui ça c'est extraordinaire
c'est d'accord sûr que ces deux races
d'hommes différentes qui vivaient
ensemble et finalement les cromagnons
ont survécu et des néandertal
il ya un excellent puisque à cette
époque-là devrait donc néandertal en
europe il y avait un cro magnon où
l'homo sapiens quoi un en afrique et en
asie oui il y avait une forme d'humanité
particulière à java ouais et puis cette
toute petite humanité particulière la
flore s1 flores et le body scan de
flores et ceux qui mesurent à mais ça
faisait quatre humanité contemporaine
c'est ça me fait signe quelques jolis
noms mais ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui
mais non j'ai surtout les êtres humains
sont pareils voiture qui avait encore
des races d'êtres humains diffuser ce
qui me semble je me permettait de
regarder au crâne au passage mafra de
qu'elles soient couverts invention
dieu qu'ils soient couverts jéthro 2
sortira sur 10 qui l'avait de différent
du cro magnon les les néandertal et
sapiens sont parties d'un même en cette
fin que l'on appelle au moins rectus
d'accord et c'est à voir absolument et
cette eau mauritus il a donné néandertal
en europe parce que quand il s'est
déployé sur toute l'eurasie en europe la
population a été enfermé enfermé par les
glaciers qui se développait à soir comme
dans l'île de lombok zettel et renfermé
absolument absolument c'était un c'est
un isolat au sens propre sani seulement
au sens propre une insularité et le
petit bonhomme là dedans il a il a dévié
génétiquement c'est à dire qu'il est
devenu autre chose et il est devenu ce
thème de néandertal qui est plus plus
court plus trapu plus costaud avec une
tête un peu boursouflé avec un front
absent un menton absents qu'il est plus
proche du singe avec des arriérés
battant l homo sapiens il n'en est rien
il a une c'est peut-être oui donc ce
roadshow néandertal a vécu tout à fait
tranquillement en europe oui oui mais
moi je ne les j'ai fouillé par exemple
des sites
tout près de malaga dans une grotte puis
s'apaise à faraya --la néandertal cet
été
il ya très peu de temps il avait 25
mille ou trente mille ans et il était
complètement inconscient que toutes
leurs tout le reste l'europe était cro
magnon lisez il vivait tranquille
derrière ça la montagne et il a fallu
que cro magnon qui est homo sapiens
gagnent du terrain est petit à petit
s'installe en europe s'installe à java
ça sera la flore s est finalement
prévalent sur néandertal en europe sur
le cet homo erectus particulier à java
est sûre l'homme de florès de tout est
ce que c'est les cromagnons quand tu es
les néandertal bon ils ont tué me donne
une certaine manière oui nous lorsqu'on
étudie les tout-petits homo sapiens des
tout petits néandertal
lorsqu'ils ont un an le néandertal a
déjà à 70% à et non de son cerveau alors
que l'homo sapiens n'a que 50 % de son
cerveau ce qui veut dire que l'homo
sapiens a beaucoup plus de temps
d'apprentissage sur beaucoup plus de
temps de croissance et ce temps de
croissance va lui permettre d'acquérir
beaucoup plus de connaissances alors que
néandertal sera plus vite et la noix du
rogas rapidement les rsa et et
finalement c'est ce qui va sans doute
entraîner sa perte il ya des poissons
qui étaient utilisés en surfaces
chapelet de cela quand ils ont été
rebutés marre maintenant c'est sa nature
genre c'est celle à venir si l'on était
en visite mardi dix ont été embêté par
des petits poissons et sur descendu à
dire que se sont adaptés aux grands faut
et on les avait perdus de vue depuis 60
millions d'années mais
on les connaissait fossiles il ya 60
millions d'années et aujourd'hui on les
paie cher en effet commun au large des
comores sur les billets de banque mais
comment il faisait 50 millions d'années
mais un animal contre 70 ans après c
était des plus grandes découvertes en
belgique quand je veux dire c'est que
pendant pendant longtemps j'ai pensé que
l'on pouvait être faite en douceur
finale entre vivants à la surface
embêté par deux hommes qui se monte pour
être tranquille - et donc qui serait
dans l'est dans les hauteurs où on
l'atteint peu où il est apparemment très
sauvage où il est apparemment très petit
mais l'île simple au nahd qui s'est
réfugié dans les hauteurs comme le
poisson en question le sait mais quand
celles ci sont bien
moi cette histoire de poissons qui sort
de l'eau qui devient quadrupède qui
devient du pet qui grimpe aux arbres
qu'il devient un homme après mois le
chaînon manquant gelé toujours cherché
et donc j'ai beaucoup de mal à y croire
à cette cette théorie là je veux dire
que l'homme était un homo sapiens
beaucoup moins évolué aujourd'hui
puisqu'il a eu des millénaires pour
évoluer mais pourquoi les seins je
n'évolue plus voilà qu est-ce qu est-ce
qui continuent et vont continuer à
évoluer en version d'essai sur des ce
sens des ddd période tellement longue
c'est absolument la version 6 ans moi
j'ai du maire excusez moi y avons fait
ce que tu en larmes pour le chien
oui parce que l'hiver on ne sait pas ce
qu'il voulait il en voulait un jeu
renvoyé leur examen
je ne peux pas me contenter de donner de
l'évolution enfin en tout cas de la
théorie biblique pas plus que de celle
de 2,2 en
voiture gauche mais je manque
d'arguments et de culture à ce que tu as
tu crois pas que l'homme a été un va
tout a été créé en sept jours je crois
pas tu crois pas non plus qu'on était
des grenouilles et des bas c'est marrant
tu te mets à la place des paléontologues
et les fouilles qui n'a pas d'idées
préconçues il fouilla donc il fouille
dans la il est au dessus il faut dans la
première couche y trouve des hommes
comme aujourd'hui et puis dans la cage
au dessus ils trouvent des hommes un
petit peu différents de ceux
d'aujourd'hui mais qui sont très proches
de ceux qui viennent prouver au dessus
et puis ils continuent à fouiller puis
finalement ils trouvent des gens qui ont
l'air très très différents et si les
avais trouvés des premiers coups il
n'aurait pas reconnu que cela était les
ancêtres du sceau d'une salle mais mais
il a tous les intermédiaires et puis
continuez continuez continue et et puis
finalement de proche en proche il passe
alors la cheval efforts de l'âme aux
sages du singe aux mammifères des
mammifères aux reptiles dg peut-il
opa traces hier aux amphibiens des
amphibiens ou aux êtres unicellulaires
et même à la matière d'un grand coin
l'existence de nos ancêtres et de nos
aïeuls on peut absolument pas voir
l'évolution des espaces il sait sur les
périodes tandis que dix provinces et que
aujourd'hui
la technique bah moi at il dit un truc
terrible dit que la technique va
beaucoup plus vite que l'évolution
biologique de james n est que j en ai
dépassé par l'évolution certains oui
mais ça physiquement biologiquement on
évolue lentement alors que la technique
évolue très vite
et très choqué vivre merci mais ceci
c'est quoi un petit saint-pierre avec
des épices cumin pose ses choix et les
premiers légumes de printemps
ça c'est un poisson donc ça viendra un
jour en sommes c'est un peu du
cannibalisme vas-y lange avec tp et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux